what's going on everybody it's axelbeatz
here for anime uproar and the last two
chapters of jiu jitsu kaizen were a
little bit slow but everything in this
arc has come to a peak this week
including someone who is actively
hunting sukuna i don't know about you
but i think you'd have to be a little
bit crazy to try and do that if you
enjoy this video and want to see more
jujutsu kaizen content on this channel
remember to leave a like as well as
comment down below it only takes a
second but it is a huge help with the
youtube algorithm and of course if you
haven't subscribed to anime uproar make
this the video that you do subscribe and
be sure to click that bell and select
all notifications
you can also follow anime uproar on
twitter and instagram at anime uproar or
you can follow myself at excellionyt
naturally this video will contain
spoilers for jujutsu kaizen so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned so just quickly i want to cover
chapters 156 and 157 just super briefly
so that everyone is all caught up 156
picks up with fushiguro and panda trying
to get kirara to listen to them we get a
little bit more of a clear understanding
on how kirara's curse technique works
it's called love rendezvous and it's
based on the southern cross
constellation basically it assigns a
star or more functionally a number that
has to pass through a certain order
before people can move freely the order
follows how far the correlating star is
from earth if two objects or people are
marked with the same sign they will be
drawn together so for example when panda
throws a car and it has the same sign
that he does it gets pulled back
directly at him once kushiguru figures
out how this cursed technique works the
chapter ends with him pinning kirara
down 157 started with fushigoro
literally begging kirara to hear them
out and kirara does agree only for them
to be cut off when yuji is blown back
through a door onto the rooftop he is
being absolutely pounded on by hikari
but every time he gets hit he just gets
back up stands his ground and refuses to
dodge akari charges up his cursed energy
and agrees to listen for as long as yuji
can manage to stay standing we also
learn that hikari's cursed energy is
especially jagged and sharp with yuji
saying that it feels like a serrated bat
every time he gets hit hakari at first
gets upset with yuji saying he's just a
cog but yuji passionately explains that
yes he is a cog but cogs have functions
and his is to remove curses he then
turns the question around and asks what
akari's purpose is and the fire in
yuji's eyes is enough to win hakari over
at least enough to make a deal and that
brings us to the most recent chapter 158
entitled kogane the chapter kicks off
with hikari totally shocked that gojo
has been sealed which to be fair is
pretty reasonable he isn't the only one
who gets surprised though as panda
finally shares with everyone that yaga
has been killed by one of the higher ups
yuji starts to cry but panda assures him
that it's alright i don't know if i'm
ready to deal with the moment where
panda actually has to deal with his
feelings because a sad panda is never
something that my heart is able to take
hakari also mentions that the people he
is indebted to are going one after
another
implying that he and yaga have a good
relationship as well which is kind of
surprising given how much he doesn't
seem to be a fan of jujutsu high but it
does just go to show how much of a good
guy yaga really was
something else to note here is that he
says one after another implying this has
happened more than once and i'm not sure
that he would say this about gojo
considering gojo's not actually dead so
i'm a little bit curious who else he
might be indebted to that has passed
away with that though hakari agrees to
join them in suppressing the culling
game under the condition that once it's
over they help him out with his business
fujiguro says whatever he needs should
be easy enough to do and at first hikari
is totally doubtful of him but then
fushigoro explains that he is the head
of the zenin clan and we get this
amazing panel of both hikari and kirara
looking absolutely floored hikari says
it's the most surprising news he's heard
all day and with the help of one of the
major family heads his fight club will
probably be able to make some progress
as he has up until this point he calls
out to fushiguro calling him sea urchin
head and when fushiguro corrects him we
see a total shift in character for
hikari calling him fushigurokun and
saying that they should get along and be
friends with a very cute face
i love this guy he somehow rides the
line of very genuine and completely
manipulative but in a very fun way
honestly i think in general one of the
strengths of jiu jitsu kaizen is
characters being able to bring out a lot
of intensity when it's needed while also
being able to be light and fun outside
of that and hikari seems to nail that to
a t from here the group starts making
plans for what qualities they should
head to with panda saying that yuta is
heading for miyagi which on that note if
you don't really know that much about
yuta and want to know more about his
story you can check out our video from
the other day about the upcoming movie
which will focus on yuta plug aside
though kogane pops up and starts ringing
kogane is essentially a curse who acts
like a speaker to inform all culling
game players on any big updates
and there is a big update a new rule has
been added to the culling game for the
first time and from here on out players
will basically have a leaderboard for
the game where they can see the names
points numbers of rules added and
residing colony of each other player
which is pretty interesting and adds a
level of strategy to the game and then
we cut over to kahimo hajime a new
character who was first shown surrounded
by blood and darkness as he stares down
the corpse of someone he blasted into a
wall he is apparently looking for a
strong opponent saying that he hasn't
been challenged at all and that 400
years ago was much better specifically
though he is looking to find sukuna as a
result he chose to spend a hundred of
his 200 points to add the rule
disclosing information 200 points by the
way means that he has killed at least 40
people so far and the game is literally
just beginning the group is initially
surprised as to why they are getting
updates but none of them are technically
in the game yet since they haven't
entered a colony but it was likely
because of sukuna when he was still
alive sukuna probably made a contract
with kenjaku to become a cursed object
and part of that contract was playing in
the culling game but now yuji has
consumed sukuna's fingers and he is
being held accountable for sukuna's
actions fushigoro and yuji pull up the
list of players and begin coming up with
a plan if they can find someone with a
hundred points who has no intention of
adding rules they can try to force them
to add rules themselves and when it
comes to people with over 100 points
there are only two being higuruma hiromi
with 102 points and kashimo hajime who
we met earlier with 100 points now
something to note is that this meant
hajime had nearly double the points of
the person in second place
whatever this guy's deal is he is
absolutely going to be a threat now the
rule that they want to add to the game
is one that would allow them to bypass
their biggest weakness currently any
player who doesn't have their point
total change within 19 days will be
eliminated so if they add a rule that
allows players to transfer points back
and forth between each other they can
constantly bounce a single point every
few days to keep their total changing
then if possible they could add a second
rule allowing players to exit the game
by spending points
which
might be allowed despite it
contradicting earlier rules if they can
get someone else to swap in for them
either way though the plan from here is
clear while they look for a person who
can release gojo from his seal they will
hunt down hajime and hiromi and try to
add these new rules and with that this
crazy chapter comes to an end we both
made some powerful allies as well as got
a look at some very dangerous new
enemies it's great that we have hikari
on our team now but how strong will he
be really i doubt he was really going
all that hard against yuji but he did
say he expected him to be killed in the
previous chapter so he might just be
used to going easy on people because
minimal effort is enough to kill at the
same time though hajime is super scary
40 kills in such a short time is nothing
to ignore and he's willing to hunt down
sukuna on top of that if that doesn't
spell out someone who's incredibly
dangerous i don't know what will also
what's all this about him saying 400
years ago was better just how old is
this guy and is he possibly another
cursed spirit similar to sukuna himself
i don't believe we know all of these 16
special curses yet so who knows maybe he
could be someone who's inhabited just
like yuji is except in this case
possibly the curse already took him over
that's really my only guess at this
point as to how he could be over 400
years old of course we also get a look
at hiromi who kind of gives me like a
frankenstein vibe and it seems like he
uses a mallet when he fights
obviously we spent more time with hajime
this chapter but where hajime has more
of a clear crazy feeling to him hiromi
looks like he has a dry brutality vibe
going on and i am super excited to see
more about him in the coming chapters
but what did you guys think of this
chapter i personally am super glad this
fight club arc is done with and we can
get back into the more serious stuff as
well as learning about these new
villains who are just super interesting
to me i'd love to hear your thoughts in
the comments down below though as always
if you enjoyed this jiu jitsu kaizen
video and want to see more please leave
a like and if you're new to anime uproar
remember to subscribe and ring that bell
by selecting all notifications you can
help guarantee that you don't miss any
of our future videos finally you can
follow anime uproar on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar or you can
follow myself at excellionyt i wanna
give a big thank you to all of our
patrons over on patreon who allow videos
like this to be possible especially the
patron of legend the one who's
acknowledged by lord twego himself alpha
sigma as well are the one tier patrons
the ones who stand above all clans in
grata patahepha al-jatal hinokami and
water the toasted chi the spike 8227
corey mcgowan dylan isadore spidey life
tennelle tungsten tarkis baked buddhist
cody hebert and monkey d quilly finally
our pro hero tier patrons gilgamesh the
red haired raven anel cruz rathwind de
aura very gucci alicia octor bonnie
parks joanne garcia ted no ted fatboy
games and soulrise slice and dice if you
enjoy our work or maybe think we just
offer a little bit of extra enjoyment in
your day to day life please consider
going to patreon.com anime uproar and
supporting the channel for as little as
one dollar you will get your name
featured in future videos as well as
have access to our exclusive patron only
discord you can also join the youtube
channel by clicking that blue join
button next to the subscribe option but
whichever way you support us you will
get these same great benefits thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time stay excellent
[Music]
okay